hopefully no ads just ran for self
lubricating pocket catheters it's a
great product I highly recommend you go
and get them um Michelle you were
talking about go out I know I know but
no I won't sell any product that I don't
use so glad to have this next guest on
was actually the first guest ever on the
show and now author of the new book
that's just making the rounds who built
that the awe-inspiring story stories Bob
now I screwed up she's never going to
come back of American tinker printers
Michelle Malkin thanks so much for being
on hey thanks for having me back Steven
alright good now that I got that intro
out of the way let's stop acting like
it's formal because that's all right I
did I took my shoes off okay well there
you go well just don't step around Dick
Morris um so let's we we have soiled
this entire segment right off the bat
it's my fault
oh yeah lady and I ruined it um reset
button reset button uh anyway I was
gonna well let's just go straight to the
book that you're making the rounds now
well firstly before we get to that
Michelle you know we've talked about
this a lot you kind of took I guess
would you say a sabbatical from most
media for a while I did I needed it I
you know you were in it you know what
it's like yeah to be able to maintain
that every single day and not feel like
you're just about to have a heart attack
or you know need a permanent hot shower
and you know the reason why we can do
things like that is in large part
because of the alternatives we have as
social media entrepreneurs you're doing
it now and it afforded me and it
afforded my family a kind of freedom
that I would have never envisioned when
I embarked on my media career almost a
quarter-century go when you had to be a
company man or a company woman right now
let me ask you this are you I know
you've been you've been kind of I guess
dipping your toes back in the water are
you mainly going to be doing media to
promote pieces of content like your book
or do you think you're gonna you're
going we're going to be seeing the
Michelle Malkin
on traditional media anytime soon um you
know I was very grateful for my the
friends that I do have at FoxNews who
you know welcome to me that back with
you know just with great grace to talk
about the book I think it's really
important to reach those platforms
especially with the message of this book
um but but no I mean I like my freedom I
like being out in Colorado uh there are
other things that are you know way more
important to me and always have been the
reason why we failed on the East Coast
in the whole DC New York scene in the
first place and you know because we can
be on Twitter and on the blog and on
Facebook and disseminate our message in
in in other ways um you know I don't
have to be on kind of like the daily TV
treadmill arm right but you know for for
a book launch and a book campaign I make
no bones about I'm trying to reach as
many people as possible here yeah and
it's funny you say that isn't it a
wonderful feeling Michelle that nobody
can fire you yes I I really think it's
it's the the most liberating feeling of
all and I think you know back when I
wore the corporate media hat and it
really was the only choice around I
worked for two major newspapers you know
syndication and early blog hood gave me
a taste of that freedom and obviously
I'll never regret a moment of all of the
work that I put in you know those past
ten years when you know when you saw my
face pretty regularly on TV I I just
think you know when when you're when
you're trying to balance have different
needs and wants it's so much easier to
do that when you have the world of the
internet and bits and bytes right -
sulla vacuum no I think you're so right
and I know I know this is probably way
more personal than me of the other
interviews but listen we've talked about
this before I think last time you were
on when I also worked in traditional
media I've always said this I've never
said anything that I didn't believe
but there is absolutely some truth to
the fact that I didn't really get to
focus on the things that I truly
believed in the things I was passionate
about and that's just because listen
there are certain things that are an
easy sell in traditional media and
certain things that aren't and I don't
begrudge anyone at all for that do you
feel like now being completely
independent off in your own immensely
successful Island we make it sound
quaint I mean let's be done very very
well you've been a real trailblazer do
you feel like this book now is is a more
accurate reflection of the things that
inspire you then you've maybe done in
the past well I think it just provides a
deeper broader understanding or picture
what motivates me and you know that of
course every day is you you make choices
about what you're going to drive what
message you're going to drive home and
and there's this question of who picks
the frame um so you know when you're
going to do a segment on TV it of course
it's it's natural you don't pick the
frame and so the picture that's
presented is not necessarily one that
represents you know completely who you
are and this is why I started off the
book joking about how a lot of people
perceive me as being that angry brown
lady on TV but you know for most of the
people who have met me on this
you know the speaking trail or who have
had any chance to interact with me
personally they know that's just one
small aspect of of my personality and
just like you said Steven because I
always say it - I'm very proud that I
have never said anything on TV or radio
or anywhere else that I don't absolutely
believe because I feel as if and I know
you do - Steven that if what's the point
okay
what's the point of having a platform or
a microphone if you are you know turn on
some sort of of personality that isn't
completely authentic I mean really live
right the place yeah to sell a boatload
of self-lubricating pocket catheters
that's the point that's why some of them
they get tempted by the mountain of - no
that's that's why I understand that I
just I feel like I couldn't be I could
not have sustained you know 25 years of
going out there and putting yourself on
the line and you know what it takes
Steven because you know it's you know it
it's putting it's putting yourself at
risk for your family at risk I in in
dire ways that you would have never
thought possible when you embarked on
why can't I cut you off with the go to
break and I want to bring you back and
we'll get more into what you're saying
and the book michelle malkin who built
that ladder with credit we'll be right
back and we are back hopefully no ads
just ran for self lubricating pocket
catheters it's a great product I highly
recommend you go and get them um
Michelle you were talking about go out I
know I know but no I won't sell any
product that I don't use I tell you what
Michelle if you have not you you haven't
lived until you've used one of your self
lubricating pocket couch I'm sorry again
we started uh this is a nice yeah we
turned us into this whole you know
philosophical thing it's pretty cool
it's it's you will you always do this I
love this as well I love talking to you
because you know everyone else is so why
did you write a book what what is it -
my question from your publicist and I
was like I mean she seems very nice I'm
going with it what the hell I don't want
this list of questions well you know a
lot of times people just want to be fed
I mean you know that's the thing and so
that's the thing there's a lot there's a
lot of people out there who I mean in
this is I just don't I just feel like
there's no time to waste and I never
want to feel like I'm phoning it in
right now and you see people all the
time and you think man what a waste
what's wrong with you I know clearly
compassion passionate about what you do
look what you're able to do well you
were pretty passionate on Twitter the
other day I dare I say a little bit of
profanity made some appearances well
geez which one was that safe a nice
little brown lady I don't know I know
what I know what it was yeah it was a
you know typical story of left-wing
blogs lying and you know accuse me of
falsely accusing me of using some
doctored photo on
article that was syndicated and then run
by National Review and you know what I
hate I don't care if you're on the left
on the right
if you can't man up and take
responsibility for your mistakes or
errors yeah I'm going to call you out
that's a great thing about Twitter and I
think it's another great thing about
being independent because if you're not
on you're not on some it's not like high
school where you're on some team and
you're always on that team right or you
know whether they do right or wrong and
I think that's the way I've been with
when it comes to uh you know criticizing
the Republican Party and just the way I
love my wife oh by the way I hate to
stir up drama but I'm totally going to
did I tell you how god I didn't really
realize I went on Alex Jones a show to
disagree with him and I basically got
him to apologize to you
really he said he was i I swear to you
he said he said you know I think there
were some things that went down he said
I really do support most of what she
does and I think we should all be
joining together so I'm just saying you
know I I don't know what's going on
there but it was surprising to me and
for those listening I went on and
disagreed right away with Alex Jones so
don't don't send me letters yeah but
yeah was it was a fascinating sort of
discussion but you know what you're
you're right and it doesn't like there
are a lot of people that are phoning it
in and I've talked about this with
Andrew W K and I think Milo innopolis
last week you know this is abnormal I
know for people like you and I who've
done media for so long but this is kind
of the way media is going for younger
people they want things that feel a
little organic and my theory has been
you know when when our parents were
growing up it was let's sit on at the
dinner table and talk and then we'll sit
and we'll watch you know The Tonight
Show or we'll watch Steve Allen and it's
all boy gee betcha whereas now people
aren't talking with each other they're
so married to their device they're
looking to their entertainment and
that's sort of the podcast phenomenon
for that sort of human touch and
interaction they want it to feel more
conversational I don't know if you've
picked up on that because you sort of
always have your finger to the pulse of
how media evolves have you have you
noticed that with younger people yeah I
certainly do um I don't know if this is
the best example of it it's just
something that's been on my mind lately
but my oldest my daughter had one
the Twitter account she really really
really wanted one and uh you know I I I
had hesitated and I let her do it and
then she felt like she was talking to an
empty room because none of her friends
were on Twitter
so think about she's a she's that she's
a high school freshman she is fairly
well informed very politically aware
without really much of a hand a direct
hand on my part but at this stage in her
life I think if she had to define
herself as anything she should say she
was libertarian-leaning and and she's
not on Twitter but you know we're all
the kids are Instagram Instagram and
snapchat and I went to Instagram and it
was basically knew nothing but
pornography so I I didn't go back well
you know I up an Instagram account oh I
don't know several months ago mostly as
a tool to do something that we've just
been talking about which is sort of to
provide a fuller richer rounder picture
of who we are I think that one of the
troubles that the right faces is this
this problem that I've caught talking
about about framing framing who we are
it serves useful purposes to be
perceived all the time as you know an
angry person who is you know fully
immersed and obsessed with partisan
politics and that's not true and the
more you you are able to make yourself
look like a human being the more
dangerous it is for the progressive
right now you're absolutely right and
the problem is Michele that you and I
both know this the a lot of people who
sort of control the more conservative
mediums don't want that they want the
talking points and that's where I've
never seen anything I don't believe but
I definitely know listen I used to do
all the radio circuits and I don't do
any media now unless it's a good close
friend that's my general rule
just because a I don't really need it
and B I just it got to a point when I
was just going align know what they want
me to say and I'll throw in a few
punchlines but like you said it doesn't
present the whole picture as to who you
are and leftists are so good at creating
stars and creating these personalities
and and I feel like the write really
misses that because like you said if the
oh really knew you more clothes I know
you as I know you I think there are a
lot of people who have these sort of
preconceived notions about you that
would have their mind change but you and
I know the only way to get them to see
that is is through your own social media
it's not going to happen today yeah
exactly exactly
but I will say this just to sort of
temper or leaven everything that I've
said you know I've been around enough
and you know interacted with so many
just really wonderful grassroots
conservatives yes and what they hate
most about the the GOP establishment is
the fact that these people never fight
back and you see them on TV and it's
clear that their main agenda is to get
invited back on the show - Chum it up in
the green room and so whether it's you
know appearances that I did on the view
for the last book or with Matt Lauer you
know or even just last week where you
know I had had been on hiatus for from
Fox for a long time I did the whole you
know book promotion and then they had me
on for a segment on one of these shows
where they put me up against some dumb
open borders liberal and yeah my head is
going to explode because I can't stand
what I'm hearing and for the most part
these people get away with it so yeah I
think it's cathartic and I think there
is a utility to you know if you've got
three minutes to you know completely
expose some open borders traitor yeah
you're going to do it but like I said
you know the framing is really important
because you don't want to I don't want
to just be seen as somebody who you know
hey immigrants and that's why I went off
on the guy in the first place right this
I that we all just want to all throw
every last foreign person into into a
cattle car I mean it's it's ridiculous
and it does make me am mad yeah very mad
but the truth is though you'll be
authentic about that and and that's what
I appreciate where's like you said you
hit the nail on the head there I think a
lot of people miss it
people have points of view or they have
things they want to say but their main
goal is to make sure they can get back
up again and so you're going like oh you
were right on that you were on the logic
trail to a good point and then you
curbed it what happened and it's very
friend and I don't think you've really
ever done that and so that's where you
know it's the old Wayne Gretzky quote
don't go where the puck is go over the
pucks going to be whenever everyone else
is so busy playing the game you stood
out and that made you more in demand I
think I spoke about this on air you know
I've worked with there have been a
couple of people Michele who have
approached me about sort of syndicating
the show we're on in a couple stations
and then what comes with it is okay they
get to pick the sub host or they want to
have control over the guests and so once
the conversation turns to me going go
screw yourself we don't really need it
and thanks anyway it all of a sudden the
dynamic changes and people find that
interesting and I think that's what's
interesting about you if you're in a
panel and there's three other people or
if you're on debating two other people
and their goal is okay make sure I get
back on the show it's a very different
there's going to be a very different
path taken to that end goal then okay
make sure I'm right and truthful and I
think exactly exactly that that that's
right and I would say that the most
enjoyable TV appearances I've had since
I've gotten you know back into it the
last couple of weeks were the longer
form programs and segments I did 45
minutes on c-span and God bless c-span
you know it's it's always
no-holds-barred there and they've always
they've always been great about just you
know giving me a fair shot and and when
it's more conversational and really when
somebody's yelling at you and and you
know calling you the most evil person on
earth and you're able to do more than 30
seconds and and really reveal you know
the truth about who the real haters are
it's really enjoyable it's a lot of fun
um and um and then the other thing I did
recently was I I got to speak at the
reagan ranch last week and they're going
to be showing that on c-span again and i
think it's really important to reach
that kind of audience because people
will give you a shot because they know
it's not just going to be 30 seconds
amount and you have time to develop your
ideas and that's what i got to do with
this book as opposed to not the other
reason why i was really mad the other
day stephen was um
Washington Post book reviewer who was
mocking the chapter that I did on toilet
paper hits thinking that this was so
funny in and of itself
QED um because he couldn't wrap his head
around you know possibly uh reading the
whole thing digesting it and
understanding the thrust of what I was
trying to do which is what you tried to
do with so many and done successfully in
your past videos of in particular
reaching younger people remember that
the segment you do with the kids in the
Halloween candy which might still one of
my kids favorite segments um of you know
really driving these lessons about a
free market economy home yeah well you
know it's it's a while first off I'm
very I'm actually more more flattered
when your kids compliment me Michele no
offense it's like for people who don't
realize they're their children are these
absolute just total talent these massive
talent pools where you look at it you go
oh my gosh
I wish I were as good at anything as
this kid is at music I'm a loser and it
makes me want to go swallow a sword is
not the Asian thing is that are you the
tiger mom is that what's going on well I
had a mountain lion mom and yeah I'm
look like the marshmallow woman compared
to her I but you know I think that
inculcating that sense of drive and work
ethic and um that there's a Latin phrase
that I include at the end of the book
which is really our family motto me Hill
bunny sin labore a there there's nothing
great achieved without work yeah there's
a lot more for the day dude unless
you're a Kardashian and that includes
just tucking your your sub behind your
legs right now they give the word for
that Michelle I'm sorry I took the
conversation to wait you know what let's
uh let's let's hit the refresh and bring
on for the last segment we can talk
specifically about your book I know
you've talked about that everywhere else
but my audience may not necessarily be
familiar with it because there are a
couple things I think are important for
everyone to know and you should drive
that point home Michelle Malkin Lauder
with Crider we'll be right back we are
back with michelle malkin now is the
point where I justify having brought her
on the show so this book who built that
on inspiring stories of American at
tanker preneur Zhai that's a hard word
tinker preneur it's obviously sort of a
shot back over the bow on you didn't
build that from Barack Obama um did this
come from a place because you yourself
are I don't say this I don't wanna be
one of those interviews where all I'm
doing is you know kissing up but you I
mean you're you're you're pretty much a
pioneer you blazed a lot of new trails
with some of the things you did in the
in the the online sphere was that a big
inspiration for this well I appreciate
that and I really appreciate just your
public recognition of that because you
know again I think it's it's a it is it
serves the left purposes to not
acknowledge you know the full breadth of
who you are so it's much easier to just
you know consider me the these phrases
that would that have been bandied about
for last
you know decade and a half on on online
that I'm just some white man's puppet
you know like yeah I actually did think
of these business ideas and I let me
real quick clarify what that is because
it's important I said you know no one
was doing the the Twitter aggregation
sort of news timeline before you did it
at twitchy and people were furious and
listen I wasn't saying you invented
Twitter okay I'm working I like you
Michele I don't like you that much I
wouldn't like me that much exactly I was
saying that news sites you know they
might mention offhandedly like Ashton
Kutcher said something stupid and there
might be a hyperlink to you know Twitter
but you were the first one to put in a
timeline in a way that was entirely you
know graphically accessible this is what
happened on Twitter this is a narrative
and that was the entire news story not
tossing it in with commentary you were
the first person to do that and I was
amazed that people were mad at me giving
credit well yeah and I think there was
partly it was deliberate
misunderstanding deliberate
misunderstanding right and also again
because you know if if people
acknowledge that yeah I had something to
do with that yeah I had an innovative
thought again I think it's you know it's
something that does not compute in their
worldview and that's why you'll never
see me at South by Southwest or up there
with Arianna Huffington I have to tell
you Steven when I when we first rolled
out twitchy you could I mean you can go
back and look unless of course they
deleted them I didn't
to save any of these stupid tweets of
people who had no idea what I was doing
they didn't understand it they thought
twitchy was the stupidest thing even
some former so-called colleagues at
other sites that I had created
um snarking about we want name now 41
everybody no I'm not I know I know
I'm being Christian so look you know
this is something that of course every
disruptive innovator from the Industrial
Age to the Internet age has had to face
whatever the degree obviously was so
much smaller than mine you know it's not
a huge breakthrough I think it was
inevitable that you were going to see
Twitter aggregation we just happened to
be there among the first and I think it
was really important to get a gain a
foothold in that because I think the
right has been caught flat-footed so
much and I wanted to be ahead and and
and we were and I'm really proud of that
and I think that this idea of disruptive
innovation I think really captivated me
and that's why I was so you know really
keen on doing this book it was really
like taking a graduate course in the in
the history of American innovation now
would you say well I guess I'm
let me scrap that question I was going
to say if you focus if you feel the need
to focus more so on inventions or sort
of improvements because it seems that
the United States now doesn't maybe
invent as much but they improve upon
things really really well they innovate
things or you know they're creating
better mousetraps do you think we're in
a stage right now in American history as
you research this book where it not
everything under the Sun has been done
but a lot of it has and so you see more
entrepreneurs you know like the
Zuckerberg people who didn't invent the
internet but they're creating the
Facebook they're creating the Instagram
does that seem to be where the puck is
going yeah I think I think so and you
know actually that's that's a trend that
traces back to the Industrial Age and
and that's one of the things that makes
our free market economy you know such a
marvel I have a quote from de
Tocqueville in the book that talks about
how you know what makes America great is
not to be endeavours of a few huge
product products and projects but the
confluence of of an amazing amount of
small ones
and that's that's the history of whether
it's the bottle cap or the or the razor
blade or even the development of glass
bottles in this country that it was you
know one insight that was labored upon
and tinkered upon for years and years
and years and continually improved and
of course the ability to profit from
those large amounts of improvements over
time I mean the people that I highlight
didn't just have one or two patents they
had 200 or 300 or 400 this should have
gone on Shark Tank they shoot out by
Kevin oh that's you know what that's
that's another thing you know we talked
about that there seems to be because
conservatives love to write off
Millennials you know I mean and yes
they're far the left but there really is
if you look at their investment patterns
they're not rolling the dice in the
stock market but they actually are
investing long-term and diversified
portfolios they're they do believe in
higher taxation and Bernie Sanders but
then you look at them and a lot of them
are really trying to swing for the
fences and become entrepreneurs do you
think the American entrepreneur is like
a lot of people on the right say kind of
kind of dead with my generation or do
you think that it'll be even bigger than
ever well yeah it is thriving in a way
and it is that indie spirit which has
sort of been the theme of the of our
entire Stumm show here of people who
want to work for themselves now it's
paradoxical because on the one hand
shows like Shark Tank are wildly popular
and yet these same millennial sources
who are striving to hit it big vote for
people whose entire careers are based on
demonizing the financially successful so
why is that
why don't they connect the dots I think
a lot of it has to do with just a
complete vacuum and absence of
historical lessons that would immunize
them to this well shaming cancer that I
talked about I mean I quoted yes I
quoted Bruno Mars the other day he's got
that song billionaire which he no they
all bought their heads too because I
want to be a billionaire so freakin bad
right by all the things I never had and
at the same time they listened to Obama
the the class war
you're uh spitting out the words
millionaire and billionaire like they're
profanities right that is true that's a
good point I remember actually when the
last time I saw I think your your
husband was coming back from Bruno Mars
concert with you and we happily fork
over our heart and earned money right
yeah no exactly it's a good point I
think there's a disconnect I I don't
know if it's I mean you have people who
are staying in school longer a lot of
them haven't paid taxes socialism is no
longer a dirty word because of the I
mean institution of higher learning and
of course the media I mean if you look
at Bernie Sanders I it's amazing but
he's gaining so much traction with
people my age dare I say it even more
than Hillary with the leftist and these
same people are often the people who are
innovating and creating these amazing
services online so it is there is a real
sort of dichotomy there and I don't know
that I have you know I try and provide I
don't know that I have any kind of an
answer for it other than hopefully
they'll grow out of it I mean I don't
know how when you know the Common Core
af-- ocation of the teaching of AP US
history the teaching of AP of econ
economics in this country is now you
know thoroughly saturating I mean it's
it's it's it's not just college it's not
AP US history courses it's it's pre
school where you've got an entire cadre
of
social justice warriors turning our kids
against entrepreneur to proneural ism
and obviously you know these these
people who are coming out of the
teaching core the Teach for America
types what do they do what do they make
they make trouble they are leaving the
Baltimore and Ferguson protests right
I'm feeling a lot of micro aggression
from you right now I'm not gonna yeah I
know we actually were doing a video on
that Jill is that not a single person we
asked not one knew what micro aggression
was except for gender studies feminists
I can't wait to see this oh and by the
way and like the one lady this is
totally off camera my video producer
jared is here this one girl was tall and
she was like I want to talk about this
off camera that's it okay excuse me you
don't know what it's like to be a woman
and experience sexism at listen Michelle
I I say this is yours but you're a your
small lady I mean you know you've been
around my wife and I it's the land of
giants uh it's our wedding was like
straight out of a page of Hitler Youth
every single bridesmaid
six foot pointed you can speak okay
that's going to be take clipped and
taken out of context I know yeah
but but the lead Dorn was also there and
I turned to him and I said Lee he was
one of my one of my kruseman and I said
Lee I'm so sorry that you feel so Jewish
I said I know it's this is the whitest
wedding everyone looks like their area
and he said no no I get it they all
they're all related to your wife yes
it's Russian German like pure that is my
wife's bloodline so it comes with a look
but um this gender studies feminists
said you know what it's like to be a
woman and I think you would know
Michelle and she goes um you know some
guy who I was walking down the street
today just you know the stuff they say
that's all like what someone
complimented me on my smile I kid you
not I said well first up she was lying
cause she had a horrendous smile there's
I'm sorry it sounds show but she was not
an attractive woman who you would say
hey beautiful smiles and it's more of a
snarl
I said well great and she just couldn't
believe I said that well you don't know
you ever have anyone compliment you and
your smile is now because I've got a
snaggletooth but I would like to and
we've an entire generation of people who
are just offended I know anyways this
doesn't go back to the entrepreneur
thing but I think that still is
reflected in this disconnect even with
the entrepreneurial spirit people who
are out there who want to strike it big
yet they vote for people who punish them
for that people who want free speech who
want this forum of ideas get their
social justice warriors and they don't
see it and and that does frustrate me
and I think a big part of that is ISM
honestly an absence of the right even
reaching out to them well yeah I mean be
what you were describing with
microaggression and then these feminists
I mean I experienced it all at Oberlin
and I always talk about the Oberlin
ization of America and I think that kind
of ties everything together here because
they're not actually actual actually
imparting knowledge of history into kids
brains from preschool through college
and beyond and then a lot of these
people who of course are majoring in in
gender studies or multiculturalism are
the people who are then going back into
the elementary school classrooms so what
does that bode for innovation what does
that bode for the next generation of
makers and
elders well it means that these these
young people are not getting their
education inside the classroom they're
getting them outside the classroom and
the last chapter I talk about the
history of prosthetics in America from
the Civil War to the present and I do
have some sense of hope because I quote
these girl scouts who made this Lego
powered prosthetic hand for a little
girl a toddler who had been born with a
congenital defect and somehow these
girls maybe through their Girl Scout
Troop I don't know what but parents or
grandparents who still have some sense
of appreciation for innovation and
intellectual property rights one little
girl said I'm so glad that we're getting
a patent because it means that we've
made it so so yeah well let's put them
in touch with Caitlyn Jenner and they
can help each other some Lego you've
been thinking about her him way too much
yeah I know I know I honestly have and
you know it's okay I'm not there are so
many things that's a topic for another
day and we're actually I would have some
people yeah exactly
I'm sorry Michelle I think I've gotten
to maybe know I've asked exactly zero
questions that were suggested by just
talking about the book yeah I know but I
really do think if people haven't read
any of your books this is a great one to
start with
and now where's the best place where
you'll to find you you're everywhere
where can people find the angry brown
lady most easily well at Michelle Malkin
on Twitter and Michelle Malkin calm on
the web this is true and do you not
anger her on Twitter I've seen what
happens not say for work yeah no it is
not what's not safe for I mean it
wouldn't be safe for the Avengers that
say you go people on Twitter I uh you
know I'd say have your back but um
matter of fact I don't I would rather I
need you to have my back more so but not
only that if you could just swaddle me
like a baby through Twitter Carrie would
be a more appropriate representation
Michelle thank you so much for coming on
and even I know I know you're not doing
the media all the time but whenever you
have anything please do come back I will
always a pleasure thanks man thank you
so much louder with grey
we will be back with more messages from
these self-lubricating pocket catheters
hey if you like this be sure to
subscribe by clicking my face here on
YouTube clicking the video next to me or
subscribe on iTunes SoundCloud or louder
with greater calm it's all free and I'm
sure many of you will still find a
reason to [ __ ] about it